genau das ist eine frage über die nicht
gesprochen wird das ist eine was
passiert wenn wir den eindruck bekommen
dass die maßnahmen zur eindämmung des
virus größeren schaden angerichtet haben
als möglicherweise das virus selbst und
es gibt leute die diese gedanken haben
und das dürfen sie auch und diese fragen
müssen sie auch äußern dürfen
ich frage mich zum beispiel was machen
wir eigentlich wenn in zwei oder drei
jahren so was wie eben oder über uns
hereinbricht
was will man eigentlich noch still legen
also haben wir überhaupt noch headroom
auf so was dann zu reagieren und was
machen wir mit unseren jungen leuten die
die es am wenigsten betrifft und die ist
am härtesten ausbauen werden in den
nächsten jahren und die leute können
sich noch gut erinnern dass es am anfang
ist es flecken der körper das war die
große rolle
und das hat jeder verstanden wir wollen
ein gesundheitssystem schützen jetzt
wissen wir aber viel mehr und drei tage
vom blog da und weiter er wird schon um
1 und der seitdem so geblieben
ich hab jetzt noch mal nachgeguckt
vorher also der vier tage verwerten
liegt bei 0 8 und 1 mal wieder ein
bisschen hoch und erlebt man wieder ein
bisschen runter und einfache menschen
verstehen mich was hat sie eigentlich
immer noch das problem ist warum immer
noch so viel alarm gemacht
und warum es so gar keine aussicht gibt
es immer wieder anfangen können ihren
beruf zu arbeiten und ein kleines
beispiel der bassist meiner band hat im
straßenbau wieder angefangen und mich
hat das dass das finde ich irre
das ist ein ganz toller musiker und das
sollte er tun sollte sein instrument
spielen